OK, why don't we get started.
So good morning everyone.
I'm Alex Bui director of the BD2K center's
coordination center.
So today we're continuing our computing overview,
with our third talk in this section.
I have the pleasure of introducing Dr. Trey
Ideker from UC San Diego.
He is a professor of genetics and bioengineering
in the Department of Medicine, and is a director
of the well-known National Resource for Network
Biology and the San Diego Center for Systems
Biology.
He is a fellow at the American Association
for the Advancement of Science, as well as
of the American Institute for Medical and
Biological Engineering.
Some of you may already actually be familiar
with Dr. Ideker's work.
He is the founder of Cytoscape an opensource
bioinformatic software platform.
That some of you may have been used before
for visualizing molecular [? interaction ?] networks.
So today Dr. Ideker is going to share some
of his experiences and insights into the practical
challenges of running a research lab at the
intersections of data science and biomedicine,
something that several of you will likely
face in the future.
So Dr. Ideker, thank you for joining us today,
and the floor is yours.
OK, very good.
Thanks very much for that introduction.
What I'm going to talk about today is really
four points that I consider to be key considerations
when you build a data sciences laboratory.
I'll talk a bit about my own work through
vignettes to illustrate these four points.
These, of course, aren't the only four points
that one might want to consider as one builds
out their own data sciences laboratory or
improves an existing data sciences laboratory.
But they're certainly four of the more important
points in my experience.
The first thing I'll talk about is lab mission,
and this is first because it underlies it
underscores everything that you do in the
lab.
Why do you get up in the morning?
Is it technology, biology, medicine, or something
else?
And clearly articulating the vision as specifically
as possible.
But with as much vision as possible.
I'll spend most of my time in the next hour,
or in slightly less, talking about getting
data.
It turns out the more you think about places
and sources of data, whether they be external
or internal to the lab, through collaborations,
or one on ones, it's a very key issue in the
life of a scientist.
So most of my talk actually ends up really
focusing on one sources of data.
Near the end, I'd like to touch on computing
infrastructure.
So of course, one needs to think as a data
scientist about what is the hardware that
one needs to have in one's environment.
And then finally, I will say a few words about
tools development process.
Process ends up being more important than
one might first realize in terms of one's
research flowing into development and ultimately
tool dissemination.
So that'll come at the very end of the talk.
So without further ado, let me take the first
issue on.
Lab mission.
And the way I think about this is really why
one
as a data scientist would want to go to work
in the morning, and what keeps you getting
up in the morning and going to work every
day.
Of course all of us have our reasons, but
there really are three important reasons that
I can think of in terms of driving your research.
One is biological discovery.
So is the most important thing in your life
questions or statements such as, I want to
reveal how biology or life is structured,
of functions, and evolves.
Now as a data scientist, let me make it clear
that you are going to be using the tool box,
among other tools, of data science.
A chemist could ask this question, a geneticist
could ask this question and they would be
using a different toolbox.
And of course one's free to use multiple tools
from those different boxes.
But the point is it's very possible to be
a data scientist, yet your first allegiance
is to biological discovery, which might mean
you largely use state of the art tools that
already exist to answer those questions.
The next question would be medicine.
So independent of how life actually works,
I want to help people get better.
I want to cure cancer would be, if I had to
stage my lab's goal, from the medical point
of view.
But again, you want to cure cancer using a
data scientist toolbox and increasingly I
think we're seeing that the ability to cure
diseases and to push for biomedical research
into those diseases is dependent on data science.
And finally is listed here is probably what's
the most common answer to this question of
among data science individuals or labs which
is, what gets you up in the morning is the
urge to develop new technology or methodology.
So you have, and this is commonly and unfortunately
in a derogatory way, sort of referred to as
a hammer in search of a nail.
But of course hammers can easily find the
correct nail lots of the time.
But the point is, you've built a hammer and
you have a data science analysis, you have
an algorithm, a software or hardware device,
etc. that you believe is going to revolutionize,
largely, the previous two disciplines, either
biological discovery, and or medicine.
So now, like I'll do throughout this talk,
I'll try to make some general points and then
spend a few slides illustrating how I answer
those questions in my own life and lab.
So I am driven to get up in the morning because
I have the as you'll see not an unambitious
goal, I'd like to build a complete model of
cell structure and function and fully automate
that process, much like one can now build
a full model of a genome through automated,
or at least semi automated genome sequencing
pipelines.
And so just to give you a couple of motivations
and arguments for why I think that is an important
motivation in my life, I'm driven by this
idea lately that networks, like people are
generating on the left here, of either physical
protein, protein interaction, or gene expression,
or so-called genetic interaction.
There's lots of ways that scientists are linking
together molecules like genes and proteins
and cells.
The problem is with this common view is that
cells don't look like that.
Cells look much more like the picture you
see on the right, and it turns out that both
the picture on the right and the left are
the same object, or representations of the
same object.
And in cells, this is the proteasome.
The proteasome, as you may know, is the vacuum
cleaner of the cell.
We're looking at the proteasome on its side.
So here is the core in the middle that eats
the proteins, and here is the regulatory particle
on either side, and you can see of course,
the several [? faults ?] of symmetry there.
It's very hard to see that structure on the
left.
Although if one starts to peer at it, one
sees a higher density of interactions among
the core proteins, which here are the same
colors, in red and yellow.
And one sees a higher density of protein and
other interactions on the right side, among
the regulatory sub units.
But the question that, really, we've been
addressing now towards a ultimately model
of the structure and function of the cell,
which starts to look much more like the picture
on the right, is as follows.
So we're trying to come up with algorithms
and tools from data sciences point of view
that will take all of these network data,
that I just showed you here and here is in
panel A.
And first computing master gene-gene similarity
network, based on all of those raw interaction
data, but don't stop there, from gene-gene
similarity network ask the question, how far
can we push that towards what starts to look
like models of the cell?
And as far as we've gotten so far, we haven't,
I should admit, gone all the way toward structure.
That's a very, very hard problem.
But we have been able to push the towards
hierarchical models of the components of cells.
So you saw in the proteasomal case, there
were already several orders of hierarchy the
proteasome contained a core and a regulatory
particle.
Each of those contains sub units, each of
those sub units contain proteins.
So we've at least gotten as far as being able
to flesh out that type of structure, largely
directly from these kinds of interaction data.
That hierarchy begins to look a lot like what
we've already heard about in this series an
ontology.
So we directly align those ontologies with
the gene ontology to see what is the similarity
with what's been curated from the literature.
Of course this hierarchy I'm talking about
now was entirely data driven.
So just quickly, the way the way that works
is, it's a clustering algorithm with a couple
of key twists.
Rather than build a binary tree, like most
clustering algorithms, or many clustering
algorithms do, you want to build what's called
a directed [INAUDIBLE] graph, which is, not
coincidentally, the structure of a gene ontology
or other ontology.
Which means that internal clusters, first
of all, can have more than two children.
So here's an internal cluster that has three
children.
Why is that a good idea?
Because if you have a protein complex, it
can certainly have more than two sub units.
It can have arbitrary numbers, and we also
want to allow for [? cliatropy, ?] the idea
that an internal cluster can participate in
two or more parent clusters.
So it's a varying of clustering with that
twist, and afterwards you align it to a literature
curated ontology.
of clustering with that twist, and afterwards
you align it to a literature curated ontology.
And then just to give you an example of how
this works, this process was just recently
applied by my very capable grad student, [? Mike
?] Kramer, to autophagy.
And so here he's generated, or I should say,
analyzed, and we'll get to this in a second,
in the public domain, a bunch of network data,
like protein-protein interactions, coexpression,
and other types of networks.
Among the autophagy genes.
Autophagy genes typically start with ATG for
autophagy.
Now you'll suspend your disbelief here because
we're not showing you the raw data but he's
already processed these into an overall similarity
score between pairs of genes.
So you can see in the interaction data, genes
like ATG 27 and 10 are more similar, genes
like 10, 12 and 7 are more similar.
Ah and look, ATG 10 participates in both of
those clusters.
So already you need a clustering algorithm
that can correctly create both clusters for
one component.
And oh look, there's a much larger cluster
here which encompasses all of these genes
ATG 10 all the way to ATG 8.
So in the hierarchy, at right, you can start
to see that structure in what we hope is a
much more clear and interpretable way than
looking at either the raw interact omics data
or these heat maps.
So you can see here that ATG 10 is placed
into two higher order components defined exactly
by these data, and now we have a larger component
here, which contains all of these ATG genes.
The names that you see on, at least, these
blue terms come from alignment to the gene
ontology.
In the case of these red, internal subsystems,
or terms, those were not in the gene ontology
but it turns out, have literature supporting
them.
And so we were able to name those orphaned
terms and submit those names to the gene ontology
and those are now in that resource.
And then finally when you see a number here
like 183, this is a truly orphaned component.
We have evidence that it's a true component
based on the data, yet there is no evidence
and [? go ?] for that particular grouping,
and there's no evidence in current literature
for that particular and beyond [? go.
?]
You can, of course, zoom out and look not
just at autophagy but the entire cells worth
of genes, and so this tree here starts with
all genes underneath the root, again, through
alignment to [? go.
?] This is labeled a scalar component, branch
of [? go, ?] because that's what we aligned
against.
And then you see quickly you partition into
a mitochondrial part, a membrane part, and
intracellular part, especially the intracellular
part, you can name because [? go ?] names
lots of these internal structures.
But there's lots that's unnamed, and those
are exactly the new biological discoveries.
So to get back to the example of the proteasome,
here is on right here is the old picture that
you would view that in a network browser,
but now if you look at it from the hierarchical
or ontological point of view here, again based
on the exact same data you start to see the
structure of the proteasome, at least in terms
of the hierarchy, where
you have a proteasome complex, which splits
into a core and a regulatory particle, which
split into subunits, and proteins, and so
forth.
So that's an example that I'll carry forward
throughout this talk.
But let's get back to how that relates to
the lab mission.
So that definitely is a new technology rather
than a biological discovery or a medical discovery.
However, of course, once you are driven by
one of these goals-- which I'm clearly driven
by the third one here-then you have ample
opportunities, if you play your cards correctly,
to imagine at least how those would then bear
on biological discovering and medicine.
And we'll see examples of that in a little
bit.
But first, let me now talk about the second
and what ends up being the majority of this
talk, which is the very exciting and sometimes
thorny issue of where you get data as a data
scientist.
Like any topic, one can try to classify it
into different parts.
So here what I've done is try to spread out
different ways of getting data from-- or across
a continuum, where you have easy entry but
less novelty and control all the way where
you have a higher bar of entry but complete
control and hopefully more more novelty.
Although this, of course, is a broad generalization.
And there's lots of novelty certainly to be
found all throughout the spectrum.
So the easiest bar to entry, as a starting
data scientist, is of course public data sets.
It's surprising the number of data science
labs that have a perfectly good career with
only looking at public data sets, without
doing any of these other four activities that
I'm about to talk to you.
Now, if one does not like to operate in a
vacuum-- and increasingly in our connected
society we are encouraged and have ample opportunity
to work together-- one can think about accessing
data through different kinds of collaborations.
There's really many ways to think about this,
but I think about it in terms of two types--
many-tomany collaborations which are sometimes
called consortia and one-on-one more focused
collaborations between you and a coworker
who can be either at your same institution
or at a different institution.
And then finally, pushing down this pipeline
or this continuum, the last category would
be to bring those experiments into your own
lab.
And the way to do that is if you yourself
do not feel yet qualified, if you have not
been trained in biochemistry or genetics or
some other molecular biological laboratory
discipline, then I've seen lots of cases where
that lab nonetheless is able to run a very--
well, to start and then run a very successful
experimental program.
And the way to do it is with a host lab.
So this requires a lot of trust with the host
partner here.
But if you have, say, a neighbor with whom
you have a very good working relationship,
then you can often come up with an agreement
where you'll pay for an experimentalist in
their lab or you've already hired a postdoc
or a technician into your lab and they'll
mentor that person within their own lab at
least some of the time.
The final position on this continuum is to
go even further and to take on all that experimental
laboratory activity yourself.
And again, there is a lot of laboratories,
including my own, that took this plunge at
the beginning of their careers.
And I certainly wouldn't go back at this point.
And I'll talk a bit about that.
But all of these modes I'd like to say are
successful ways of running a data sciences
lab.
You just have to choose which kind of lab
you want to be.
So in terms of public data, because a lot
of what I'm focused on is building models
of cells with ultimate application to understanding
and curing cancer.
And again, every time I say that, I have to
smile, and I'm sure some of you are as well.
It's a lofty goal here.
So-- but-- but-- but the point is you want
to keep getting out of bed for 30 years, or
maybe your entire career.
You don't want to just have a goal that's
going to get you out of bed this week.
So in the case of cancer, there is-- in many
ways, cancer is the flag ship of widely available
public data.
And the jewel in the eye of that flagship
is the cancer genome atlas, or TCGA.
Where at this point in time, there there is
far in excess of 10,000 exomes, I should say
here as opposed to genomes, for cancer available.
This just shows one such genome that was an
early genome generated by the cancer genome
atlas.
This is a so-called Circos plot here, for
a single patient who had been sequenced, and
also subjected to a variety of other modes
of data collection and analysis.
But here they're really focusing on the genome.
So you can see here around the circle, you
have the 22 chromosomes plus the x and the
y.
And then in successively smaller and smaller
tracks around this circle, you can see different
types of analysis they've performed to extract
different kinds of information about the raw
genomic sequence.
So in terms of single nucleotide substitutions,
you're looking at that here in this yellow
track, just counting the number you see as
you walk along the chromosomes from one to
the other.
You can then get into the different kinds
of substitutions you see there and other kinds
of changes.
You can then get at the copy number variance
or long segments of DNA that are amplified
or deleted.
So here you can look at amplifications, deletions,
and so on.
And so then if you take a step back and look
at the collection of all data that's available
through a resource like the cancer genome
atlas, they've really made it very, very accessible.
So a few clicks away, if you simply Google
TCGA cancer, you can get to specific tissues
where all of the patient data that have been
collected for that specific cancer tissue
can be accessed.
So if one is interested in head and neck squamous
cell carcinoma, here's the data page that
you find.
So there's a total of 528 cases currently
in the TCGA, of which just shy of 500 have
been sequenced, at least for the exome.
But then I mentioned, they've collected a
whole variety of layers of molecular and then
finally clinical information, which are mostly
survival.
Occasionally you get direct response information
in the clinical column here.
But it's a lot of data and at least the first
couple of tiers of those data are pretty easily
accessible.
If one wants increasingly raw data, one has
to obtain the proper access but hundreds,
if not thousands, of labs have taken that
step, including my own.
So it's not complicated to do.
Now my lab being a network lab, we also are
very interested in public domain data sets
describing molecular networks, of which--
just like cancer genomes-- there are many.
Here I just list general categories without
mentioning the individual databases.
I'll talk about that maybe a little bit later.
But you have metabolic networks that are essentially
akin to the whole Boehringer Mannheim wall
charts people used to have in the labs-- on
the lab wall.
Transcriptional networks which have been measured
increasingly systematically with techniques
like chIP seq.
Genetic and protein interaction networks--
protein interaction networks are being measured
with technologies like [? authenity ?] [? purification
?] [INAUDIBLE] or the [INAUDIBLE] hybrid system
and a variety of other related experimental
technologies.
And again, many labs are generating these
data and depositing them in the public domain.
If all else fails, one can always take the
prolific MNRA and protein expression data
that are out there in databases like the Gene
Expression Omnibus, or GL.
And from those profiles of MRNA levels for
each gene, compute genegene similarities which
can be interpreted and used as networks.
We started putting, in my own lab, a lot of
these data but more specifically, not just
the raw interaction data, but some of the
subnetworks in the cell models derived from
those data into this database called the Network
Data Exchange, or NDEx.
This now contains-- here we show just a variety
of sources of networks this thing contains.
We certainly have a focus on cancer networks
like the NCI pathways interaction database
we're the host of here.
Because we were funded by the NCI and our
core interest is cancer.
But there is a variety of diseases and pathways
related to those here in the database.
Now when you have various kinds of data in
the public domain, I just want to give you
another vignette of ways that our lab in a
purely public domain, data-driven way has
been able to put together these different
data sets for productive line of research.
And so, what we thought we could do is use
these protein networks as a scaffold of potential
pathways in which or on which to integrate
heterogeneous patient cancer mutation profiles
and heterogeneous patient MRNA expression
levels.
Today I'll focus mainly on the patient cancer
mutation profiles, with the idea here, can
you use the networks to group patients that
may have different genes mutated into tumors,
but nonetheless are mutating the same networks
and pathways as a way of taking what have
been called in [INAUDIBLE] patients-- those
that can't be
grouped with any others for diagnosis or therapy--
and getting extra power and insight for grouping
them at the pathway level.
The algorithm we used here to do this integration
is a algorithm that's been very powerful in
network science as a whole.
It's called network propagation.
It also goes by the name of network smoothing
or sometimes diffusion, sometimes random walk
models are invoked.
All of these names are essentially synonymous
for the same underlying method.
And I won't go into the mathematics here,
but simply take you through a high level intuition
of how this approach works.
I should say these-- I'm citing two papers
here.
One is [INAUDIBLE] lab from Tel Aviv, [INAUDIBLE].
And the other is from Ben Raphael's lab, who
used this technique to develop a very successful
approach called HotNet.
And then I'll talk about in the next slides,
some of our activities.
But the idea here of network propagation is
that if you have a patient mutation data set,
I'm calling the patient genome type 1 in yellow
or patient genotype 2 in blue, the data set
will indicate some mutations in genes for
that patient.
So here are the yellow mutations in the yellow
patient, and the blue mutations in the blue
patient.
These data are extremely heterogeneous, motivating
the need for this approach.
But occasionally, you do find patients will
mutate the same commonly mutated cancer gene.
Maybe this green gene here that's mutating
in both patients is a very common player in
cancer like p53.
But the question is, can you find more commonality
than that at the network level.
And so the way propagation works is it pretends
that each mutation is a source of heat.
And that the protein interactions and other
molecular interactions you have in this network
can conduct that heat to their network neighbors,
and their neighbors' neighbors and so on,
to convergence.
And convergence depends on one parameter.
It depends on how much-- it's essentially
the ratio of heat you inject to the amount
of heat at every unit time being diffused
into the atmosphere.
So you can think of that heat evaporating
or diffusing upwards from this network into
the atmosphere.
And so, at steady state, you get some spreading
from the heat sources with those being the
hottest, and their neighbors being the hottest.
And then the temperature falling off around
that, depending on the setting [? of its ?] parameter.
And so having diffused those two data sets,
you now see that there is a large green region
over here, which represents hot proteins in
both patients.
That is to say, what we've done is we've rescored
a patient profile from a few 1's in a sea
of 0's for the genes that aren't mutated to
a quantitative score for every gene indicating
not whether it has mutated in a patient, but
its network proximity to mutations.
So if you have an upstream factor, it feels
the heat.
If you have a downstream factor, it feels
the heat and some
kind of signaling pathway.
If you have a member of the same protein complex,
then it feels the heat as the other member
that was mutated.
And that's how you can begin to get the striking
now similarities between patients.
Again Ben Raphael, using a HotNet algorithm
has been very successful at finding cancer
pathways using this approach.
And in our hands, we pivoted the question
and tried to stratify patients using this
approach.
And so here is a network that stratifies and
identifies a particularly aggressive subtype
of ovarian cancer.
The idea here is that while hardly any two
patients in this subtype mutate the same gene,
all of the patients in this subtype mutated
gene somewhere on this slide in this subnetwork.
And that's how the network knowledge helps.
Here I'm showing you evidence that these subtypes
are significant at least clinically or with
respect to survival this blue subtype is that
aggressive network I just showed you.
So if you're mutated in that, then you are
in the blue subtype with poor survival.
That poor survival replicates in future cohorts
that have come out after our initial study.
This is a second large public repository of
cancer data, by the way, the International
Cancer Genomics Consortium.
This is an Australian cohort of ovarian--
or of women with ovarian cancer.
And here we're essentially not re-formulating
this diagnostic, we're just using it to show
that if you mutate that same network, you
also get poor survival outcomes.
OK.
So that's one vignette from my group, where
it's really-- we're actually now seeing two
vignettes, I should say, where really we're
focused entirely on public data sets.
And if you can argue TCGA was actually the
result of a large collaboration.
Although what's interesting is my group is
not-- or at least was not at the beginning--
part of TCGA.
We became involved near the end, only after
the success with this method on the public
data they made available.
If you're interested in joining a consortium
from the get go, with respect to cancer even,
there are-- here I've made a short list of
four different consortia that either are just
completing or just getting started.
So the Cancer Genome Atlas itself has officially
ended.
But that is already giving rise to what's
been called the pan-cancer analysis of whole
genomes.
And that's well underway, transitioning from
exome analysis to pan-cancer or full genome
analysis of some of the same cancer tumors.
There's other satellite projects, such as
the Pre-cancer Genome Atlas, the Cancer Immunity
Atlas.
I'll talk in just a slide about the Cancer
Cell Map Initiative that I've been involved
in formation of.
There's a Cancer Cell Atlas, which seeks to
define all cell types at the single-cell RNA
sequencing level and cancer.
This project is just getting underway and
it's also a consortium, and so on and so forth.
Cell Explorer, for instance, involves imaging
and advanced image recognition capability
and building databases of tumor cell images.
So again, this is just cancer.
There is a short list in any disease-focused
area now of large
consortia to become involved in if you so
choose.
And depending on this stage of your career,
I think it's either advisable or inadvisable.
I think the clear pro of a consortium like
one of these is that there is enormous energy
in the critical mass of folks, and also funding
that can be had in a critical mass of folks
that come together around a common cause.
The con is that one can become lost in all
of that.
And so if I had any advice to someone starting
their data sciences laboratory, it would be
certainly be involved and don't make it the
only thing that you do.
I think in this day and age it's still worth
having your independent research laboratory
activity and pursuing these consortiums or
these consortia as a secondary activity.
But the pros are really quite strong, I must
admit.
And so here's-- here's just the one we've
recently formed around networks with the goal
to-- having now sequenced many, many different
cancer genomes, can we now understand the
higher order proteins network structures that
help us explain some of those mutations, and
marshalling people together to try to systematically
define those protein-protein in genetic interaction
and transcriptional interaction networks.
So now when we talk about one-on-one collaborations,
one of the nice things about having started
with public data and showing proof of concept
of a particular approach with a tool that
might come out of your lab, is now people
might get interested.
And of course, they can get interested by
reading your papers.
They can also get interested by you reaching
out to them, depending on whether they're
at your same institution or they're at a different
institution.
That's either easier or harder.
But certainly, conferences are a great place
to form those connections even across institutions.
This is a collaboration that I became involved
with after that network stratification paper
we published in 2013.
One of my colleagues here at UC San Diego
is Joe Gleason.
He was not studying cancer.
He studies rare childhood diseases.
In this particular case, he was studying a
disease called Hereditary Spastic Paraplegia
or HSP.
Joe tells me that HSP is what they call a
complex Mendelian disorder, which means that
in any one family or child, it's one gene
typically that causes that disease.
But from pedigree to pedigree of unrelated
families, then it's typically found that it's
different genes.
And that's the complexity.
So here, we were able to work together using
essentially-- not the exact same but what's
essentially a very similar approach to the
one I just described with network propagation
here-- to find a number of disease genes for
this HSP disease based on their proximity
through networks to known disease traits.
And so what you're seeing here are the seed
or known proteins from before this study.
And red are the candidate genes where we have
power for some of these genes to find them
only because of the network proximity that
you
see here.
If you just looked at the marginal association
of mutations or variants in these genes with
the phenotype, without network knowledge knitting
genes together, you would not [? be ?] [? power
?] to find those genes.
So that's an example of playing between collaboration
and one's own work with public data set activity.
But now let me talk about the last two categories
here, which are transitioning to get these
kinds of experiments going in your own lab.
And for this point, I want to invoke my hero
Sir [? Ari ?] [? Fisher ?] who has two very
relevant quotes.
I don't actually know if [? Ari ?] [? Fisher
?] had experiments going in his lab.
I think he did a lot of collaboration.
But he had a very famous quote, and then a
not-so-well-known quote that's relevant.
The first point is that if you hold your experiments
close, you control the experimental design
and validation.
And so the famous quote is to consult the
statistician after the experiment is finished
is often literally to ask him to conduct a
post-mortem examination.
He can perhaps say what the experiment died
of.
And so therein lies the problem that I think
data scientists experience all the time.
This one-on-one collaborator comes to you
and it's essentially all the work in lab has
been done.
And you can immediately see five things you
would have suggested they change about the
experiment.
And of course, if you had started at the beginning
of the projects, you might have learned of
course as much as they would have about the
particular biological problem at hand, causing
you to change your analysis or your plans
for analysis.
So the closer you can be involved at the start
of an experiment, the better for all of us
concerned.
There is of course many ways of doing that.
But one of them is by working closely with
experimentalists either in a host lab or in
your own lab.
The other point I want to make here ends up
being actually, in my career, even more important.
And it was not something that I saw immediately,
but saw over the first three or four years
that I became involved in experiments alongside
data science.
And that's that as you begin to get your own
hands wet or dirty or whatever the right analogy
is here, this miraculous thing happens, and
you become in touch with biology like no other
method.
You can certainly become very educated about
biological systems as an armchair reader of
those processes, either with text books or
literature or hearing about them.
But somehow, when you're at the bench, you
gain a completely different level.
At least in my own life it was transformative.
And the real power that you then have is the
ability to see these key biological computational
coupled problems that it's harder to see if
you're on just one side of that fence or the
other.
And it turns out [? Fisher ?] has an excellent
quote on this as well.
Sanity and realism can be restored to the
teaching of mathematical statistics most directly
by trusting it to men and women who have had
personal experience of research in the natural
sciences.
And so here, of course, he may be talking
about different ways of getting that experience,
but certainly a laboratory is a wonderful
way of really getting experience beyond data
sciences, which he's referring to as mathematical
statistics here.
Really get involved in the biological discipline
itself.
Considering this quote is circa 1930, it's
even more impressive.
And then really, the third practical issue
here is once you have data in your own hands,
you're much more assured that you're not duplicating
the efforts of someone else.
Of course, it's certainly always feasible
that someone else has done the exact same
experiment as you are.
Certainly molecular biologists, geneticists,
and biochemists also get scooped.
But it's a higher bar to be scooped certainly.
And so, if you look at my lab, we have the
pictures you might expect, like this is [? Eric
?] and [? Kay ?] in my group who are Cytoscape
team developers, looking at a network in Cytoscape.
But then you have, moving from the office
to the lab here we're generating-- this is
[? Brian ?] in lab generating network data
and [? Anna ?] analyzing some of the network
data, for instance.
And so that's been quite a fun and frustrating
and productive exercise.
And to show how it has been used in our research
plan or program here, let me go back to this
example of constructing hierarchical models.
So I already introduced this idea that we
are trying to integrate network data of various
kinds to together to build ultimately these
hierarchies or data driven gene ontologies
of a particular biological process and ultimately
the whole cell as a type of whole cell model.
Now, once one has some control over one's
experiments, one can shift from a mode in
which one is analyzing really public interactomics
data-- that's A, B, and C-- to now asking
what new data set could I generate that would
most improve this hierarchical model.
That is to say, the fidelity with which this
hierarchical model represents real biology,
actual biological systems.
And to look at that, we of course don't know
biological truth, but we do have the very
good Gene Ontology resource that's been created
from the literature over a long period of
time.
So if we use GO as at least a bronze standard
here-- it's not a pure gold standard, it's
not perfect.
But if we treat GO as some sort of bronze
standard and we ask, how will we recapitulate
GO in our data-driven hierarchical model,
that's what's been shown here on the y-axis,
just as a fraction of our maximal ability.
What I should add here is out of the box,
this approach gets about 60% recovery of cellular
component terms and their interrelationships
that are in the Gene Oncology, at least for
the budding yeast [INAUDIBLE].
For humans, it's a little bit lower than that.
So you should be thinking perfect for us,
or the best performance we can do with about
60% recovery of GO.
And that's normalized here to one.
And now what I'm going to do is remove studies
one-by-one from the public domain, and various
kinds-- genetic interactions, protein-protein
interactions, and co-expression interactions.
And after I remove a particular PubMed ID--
and that's what literally these are, is PubMed
IDs-- I'm going to reevaluate my ability,
having removed that study, at recovering GO
in my hierarchy.
And so what you can see here for at least
these three kinds of data is that if I remove
genetic interactions or protein-protein interactions,
then I do start to hurt my ability to recapitulate
Go.
Whereas interestingly, if I remove co-expression
studies all the way up into all 50 budding
yeast co-expression studies that were in the
database we accessed.
Given that you still have all of the other
data around in the model.
You don't hurt your performance.
And so this allowed us to choose, in this
case, genetic interactions as the strongest
negative slope here.
That is to say, the interactions which at
least at the present time appear to be the
most important for driving this model.
And so now, because we had a research lab
that over a few years, I geared towards interaction
mapping-- and I should say, our lab is certainly
not the highest throughput interaction mapping
labs out there.
There are many labs that surpass our capacity
of our jack of all trades lab, if you like.
But nonetheless, we have some ability to generate
interaction maps.
And so here we took 50-- this is back from
the autophagy model.
And we took autophagy genes and paired them
with about 3,000 yeast genes to look for genetic
interactions in a matrix-like format.
So all pairs of 50 by 3,000 are tested.
And we test for interaction across three conditions.
And then you can also look differentially
between-- at interaction changes between those
three autophagyrelevant conditions.
And what you find is, here's another way again
of looking at the similarity with Go.
I apologize.
We've changed here the metric.
But nonetheless, here is how well you do at
recovering GO with all prior data in the public
domain.
If you look at just this screen alone, given
you've targeted one particular process in
your lab with the right gene sets and the
right conditions, it turns out that even not
considering prior data, you can do better
than all of those public domain data.
And again, it's just because you've tailored
the data in terms of conditions and genes.
But of course, if you add both the new data
and the prior data together, the recovery
of the GO hierarchy gets even better.
And over here are some controls showing that
if you randomize things, then you [? erode
?] your performance as expected.
So that's just the latest vignette, really,
of how we've put together a public data set
analysis leading to a
collaboration with an autophagy lab with then
let us generate our own network data, and
come full circle on that systems biology cycle
I showed.
Now, I don't want to build this for everyone
here.
And I should say, there's many frustrations
with getting involved in these kinds of experiments
yourself as a data scientist.
It is a massive investment of your time that
could otherwise be going to data science research
directly.
Compounding this fact is that debugging lab
work is much slower than debugging other kinds
of computation.
And I think several of us have appreciated
that over the years.
You can press Enter and test whether your
program works in a split second, typically.
But pressing Enter in lab can take days before
you get a result.
So two, it costs more.
You have to not only maintain your space and
personnel for the data sciences part of your
lab, or the data analysis side of your lab,
you have to come up with those resources of
course for experimental side of the lab.
And that is a challenge.
You have to expand your focus, which means
that you're distracted.
You have more to worry about, and that may
make you a less successful scientist at any
particular task.
This is what people call the jack of all trades.
And so another way of saying this-- or another
implication of this is that specialized biologist
collaborators will not always be better than
you, but have a distinctive advantage over
you.
You will never be as high as they are in knowledge
of a particular biological process or the
particular tool box of experiments that one
uses to interrogate that process.
And perhaps most frustrating of all, while
you spend the time diversifying your computer
science background to learn experimental biology,
you're going to find that your colleagues
who are staying strictly in computer science
domains are going to now, over time, be better
at you at computer science.
And that's also frustrating.
But you can collaborate both ways.
I find at this point in my career even though
I started with a degree in computer science
and ended with a PhD in molecular biology,
I now am in a position where I collaborate
freely with both sides of that fence.
And I've got to.
OK.
So that was the bulk of what I wanted to talk
about today.
I mentioned that getting data was by far the
most weighty topic in my mind.
But let me just say, in the last five minutes
or so, a few words about both computing infrastructure
and process.
So I think about of course all of data science
activities require computing infrastructure.
And so how should we think about that?
I think about it in terms of at least five
tiers.
And these are not meant to be mutually exclusive.
So there's the connectivity and the interface,
which sounds trivial, but it requires some
thought in design.
You're going to have to
separate if you have a wet lab and if you
separate that out from the dry lab or that's
necessarily separate.
So you have to think about how you're going
to maintain connectivity from a data point
of view.
I [? fear ?] and I think certainly the goal
in the lab would be to provision both environments
with high bandwidth connections, both wired
and Wi-Fi.
You have to think about how your personal--
or personnel, I should say here-are going
to be equipped with their personal machines.
So again, sounds trivial but it requires someone
to think about those kinds of things which
as your lab grows can be a surprisingly large
amount of someone's time.
Now beyond someone's local desktop, you have
two major resources in the data sciences laboratory
to think about.
You have the raw CPU power or compute engines
that you'd like to be able to access and you're
going to find are a necessary part of working
with big data.
And of course, storage of those data are necessary--
is a necessary part of working with big data.
Here we use both private servers and the cloud.
The other point to make about the compute
engines is we're seeing a trend just in the
past year or two towards these GPUs or Graphics
Processing Units as ready-made cards by video
game-- made originally for video games and
high performance graphics, for those kinds
of applications.
Like companies like Nvidia.
They're essentially highly processed or highly
parallel CPUs that one can avail oneself of
if one has the right libraries.
And it turns out that now Nvidia in particular
supports the libraries for scientific computing
on GPUs, and it's really been revolutionary
to not just my lab but to a lot of labs I
know in the data sciences.
So if you're just getting started, really
look seriously at access to GPUs.
From your own lab, they're relatively inexpensive.
Now storage-wise, we do have private storage
and also cloud storage.
And the private storage, there's a variety
of reasons one wishes to have private storage.
Not least of which, as we begin to get data
sets for patience, one has to worry about
HIPAA requirements dealing with patient privacy.
And it's easier to worry about those if one
has a mobile storage unit.
But of course, we're also seeing HIPAA compliance
in the cloud.
So whether you go local or cloud, really starting
to become more of a personal decision than
one in which it's easy to advise one way or
the other.
I would say the other big consideration here
is latency.
One would like to have quick access to the
data, which of course if the connection is
to a machine right next to you, that latency
tends to be much less.
But that's also changing.
Here is what this-- all this looks like, which
I think it always helps to get some perspective.
I'm not going to spend much time on this slide
other than to say, we here have a lot of the
local machines I talked about that compute
and the storage here at the San Diego Supercomputing
Center, which is just a half campus away,
so about a quarter mile away from my lab,
with fast connectivity to both the experimental
and computational lab.
This is the schematic of that space.
And so over here, you see that this is the
compute part of that cluster.
And here is the storage part of that cluster.
And here is representation of the local machines.
And so of course, the physical location changes
between the local machines and lab and the
STSC machines and so on.
OK, so the final thing I wanted to just touch
on is software development process.
As we begin to think about our data sciences
projects, it helps greatly-- and this, I should
say, took me 10 years and a key conversation
with Dr. Tamara Munzner at UBC who urged me--
she runs a very successful lab at UBC in data
sciences.
And a few years ago, she urged me to think
about my tool development across four stages,
and whether she would accredit this to someone
else maybe she would.
But I wanted to give her her credit here.
So first is to identify and motivate the problem
or the driving biologic question, along with
the target community that most stands to benefit
from answering that biological question or
successfully solving that problem.
Stage two is develop a prototype, and not
worry about yet how you're going to convince
the world that your prototype is useful.
You've already identified the need.
Now in stage two, spend some time internal
to the lab and get out that first paper.
Once that's out, then you can focus in stage
three on making a robust software tool or
a website or database as the case may be.
And that's not the initial point of that first
paper in stage two.
That comes later.
And finally, once you have a [INAUDIBLE] that
begins to take a life of its own, perhaps
you even generates funding behind it, then
you can worry about broad dissemination and
steps you can take to broadly encourage the
community and make your approach available
and useful.
So the first time we thought about this type
of four-stage process was in planning our
national resource for network biology, where
Dr. Munzner is an advisor.
She convinced us to take all of our projects
and to make this kind of chart.
And so on the-- I'm not going to go, of course,
into any detail here, but just to show you
kind of the big organizational view of all
of this.
So [? and-- ?] [? in ?] rows of this chart,
you have that different technology research
and development projects or TRDs, the different
groups in this consortium that are signed
up for those.
But then importantly, across the columns here,
you see those four stages.
And so now all of our research-- well, first
of all planning in stage one, then research
in stage two and three, and development in
stages three and four-it all now gets thought
about in terms of a four-stage model.
In terms of, for instance, our Cytoscape software,
here's how I think about the four stages.
So, and this is, arguably for my lab, the
first software tool that came out of my lab
in collaboration with several others, started
back in the year 2000.
And so the first was to identify the driving
problem in the target community, which here,
at
the time, it was clear that molecular biologists
were generating ever larger molecular networks.
We've already talked all about the fruits
of that, 15 years later.
But at the time, there really were no tools
to analyze networks that large.
There were certainly tools for Cytoscape,
but nothing of the magnitude that was needed
or the analytical complexity that was needed.
And so that was the motivation.
We first-- decode it ended up becoming did
first was used in a series of prototype studies,
which were biological studies performed and
published over a few papers between the years
2000 and 2003.
And the actual publication and creation of
Cytoscape itself, its initial release was
in 2002.
And its initial marker paper was in 2003.
But again, it was that real evolution of the
code, stating all the way back to even the
late '90s through 2003 when we announced that
tool to the world.
Now since then, of course, we continue to
evolve the tool quite dramatically every two
to three years.
And so every three or so years, you want to
think about updating that effort with a publication.
But now, as the last thing here, how did we
get broad adoption of this Cytoscape resource?
And that really is where I think luck played
as much of a role as skill or planning.
But there are definitely lessons to be learned.
And the first big decision we made here was
to allow the Cytoscape core, or to define
and separate out a part of Cytoscape which
was called the core, and a part which were
called plug-ins at the time.
Now they're called apps after the iPhone came
along.
Giving people the ability to write their own
plug-ins or apps really changed everything
for us.
And so if you want, if you're willing again
to put in the software engineering effort,
then it can pay off in terms of dissemination
and crowdsourcing because you're giving them
a mechanism by which to very effectively crowdsource.
Many of these apps-- and there's over 200
of them that are now developed for Cytoscape--
are also themselves open source.
And so what that means is we can actually
absorb some of that technology and use it
to benefit the core in future releases, and
everyone's happy.
And that's really been a powerful model for
us.
Other things that we've done are maybe more
usual.
So we have an international meeting around
the increasing core development community
around-- and plug-in developer community--
for Cytoscape, as well as heavy biological
users of Cytoscape were invited to this.
Over the past several years, we've had a very
successful joining with the DREAM and the
RECOMB Systems Biology Conference.
We do Cytoscape in conjunction as a sort of
three-for-all.
And that's been a great development.
Of course, one also wants to foster local
community groups around your tool.
And that's-- and one can identify
individuals who are willing to take lead roles
in that.
And finally, one has to fund these efforts
as they progress and grow.
And here, I think if there's any one piece
of advice I have beyond the obvious, it's
let go of ownership.
Realize that you're going to be successful
if your software is successful.
And you want people to write grants that are
essentially extending your software or taking
ownership over your software even.
And so, becoming an open source project, facilitating
a developer community, and just letting go
of the reins as much as possible-- you know,
of course, one of course wants to continue
to contribute to the project-- has been a
really, really key guideline for us.
And so not only now do we have Cytoscape itself,
but we have this whole satellites of tools
that have been built around Cytoscape, including
the app store where you can download the apps.
Some of these apps get downloaded thousands
of times and cited thousands of times.
So they themselves in their own right are
quite powerful forces.
And I already talked about our connections
to data basis, like NDEx.
So that concludes my talk.
And I have tried to touch, really, on four
different points, which were key in building
my own data sciences laboratory, and I think
are clearly going to be key considerations
for anyone getting started or building into
the future.
And so with that, I will thank you for your
time, especially given that I think I just
competed with Donald Trump's inaugural address.
If you are still on this call, I think you
made the right decision to stay.
But with that, I will take any questions.
Thank you, Trey, for this wonderful talk.
So we actually have time for one quick question.
So the first question-well, actually, we got
a lot of questions for this.
But I'm just going to choose one.
So what are your thoughts on using-- makerspaces
for data time science labs?
Do you have any thoughts on that?
Are there any data science makers out there
who use a space like this?
That is a wonderful suggestion.
I have several lab members who are big participants
in the makers movement.
I, myself, have not-- have not tried going
down that road.
My guess is there's-- depending on what environment
you are in.
If you're in a university environment that
has a biological sciences department, my guess
is it might actually be easier just to go
to your neighbor and use their maker space
that's provided by the university.
But I would love to hear people have had experiences
with that.
OK.
Well, we're out of time.
Thank you so much.
And we'll conclude this talk today.
Thank you.